[Music]
narcos is back with a new aesthetic and
cast of characters the first season is
just dropped so I thought I'd discuss
the finale and the real-life events that
inspired the show there will be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't seen season 1
of narcos Mexico then I highly recommend
that you turn off now but everyone else
welcome to the channel and definition
and I roon it so you don't have to we
follow DEA agent Kiki played by Michael
Pena Kiki is an ambitious agent with his
back against the wall that is trying to
do good in the war on drugs like the
season that preceded it narcosis based
on actual events and a lot of what
happens in the show happened in real
life too so if you already googled the
character then you've likely seen that
he comes to a tragic end but how did it
all happen well throughout the show Kiki
is tracking a drug trafficker named
Felix and Gallardo in real life Felix
was described as the Bill Gates of
cocaine and his wealth was phenomenal
the show beautifully demonstrates how he
was able to set the stage for the likes
of Pablo Escobar and El Chapo throughout
the show Felix bribes and corrupts the
US and Mexican government so that he's
able to operate freely due to their
corruption he graduates from selling
marijuana to cocaine and rises quickly
through the ranks to become my kingpin
the show expertly highlights how people
like Kiki were betrayed and sent to
their deaths because of greed episode 10
climaxes with Kiki being tortured by
Felix for information on the ins and
outs of the anti drug operations but the
character does not give in in real life
Kiki was tortured at Gallardo ranch over
a 30-hour period before being killed his
skull jaw nose cheekbones and windpipe
were crushed his ribs were broken and
hole was drilled into his head with the
power drill he had been injected with
amphetamines and other drugs most likely
to ensure that he remain conscious while
being tortured it's a horrendous death I
really forced the US government to
realize that the Mexican police were
corrupt and they began taking things
into their own
in order to avoid another high-profile
murder Kiki's death had a huge impact on
the war on drugs as it forced the u.s.
to really analyze the situation and to
go above and beyond the confines of
jurisdiction Kiki's death really started
the war on drugs and I absolutely loved
the end of monologue that discusses that
both sides are now fighting about how at
this level
the final scene showcases that the u.s.
is now using its own secret agents to
infiltrate the country and take out the
list of top drug traffickers at any cost
in real life felix was arrested in 1987
but it was until 1989 that he was
officially charged Felix and his family
were moved from city to city and enjoyed
the benefits at the corruption amongst
law enforcement gave them the arrest of
Felix really exposed the corruption and
showcased just how deep Iran even behind
bars Felix was able to continue drug
trafficking through the use of mobile
phones however police managed to put a
stop to this by moving him to a 240 by
440 centimeter cell in a
maximum-security prison he was not
allowed to leave this area and often
complained that it was torturous Felix
still lives to this day and paying for
the horrendous crimes he committed in
order to become rich the show doesn't
capture this but at least there's some
solace in the fact that Kiki's death
wasn't for nothing
so what are your thoughts on the new
narco season did you expect the tragic
ending and how would you rank this run
against the other seasons comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's other big TV
finale American Horror Story this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]